now the vote came just hours after a
marathon news conference fight president
biden to mark one year since his
inauguration he took questions for
nearly two hours at o'keefe is at the
white house with more on the story ed
was one of the longest news conferences
people have seen clearly he had a lot to
say he sure did he sure did gail good
morning he took dozens of questions on
issues ranging from the pandemic to the
future of his legislative agenda but on
that issue of voting rights he became
the second consecutive american
president to raise concerns about future
election results
during his news conference president
biden was asked if he believes this
year's elections will be fairly
conducted and the results legitimate
given that his voting reform bill didn't
pass well it all depends on
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election i
think you're going to see the people
were trying to keep from being able to
show up showing up and making the
sacrifice the president also touted
accomplishments we've seen record job
creation record economic growth in the
past year and admitted setbacks should
we have done more testing earlier yes
but we're doing more now the president
is facing sagging polling numbers and
doubts about his handling of the
pandemic and inflation on the pandemic
he asked for patience
some people may call what's happening
now the new normal i call it a job not
yet finished
it will get better and addressed
concerns about covid's school closures
we're not going back to closing schools
schools should stay open
since congress failed to pass his
sweeping buildback better plan biden now
says break it up i'm confident we can
get
pieces big chunks of the buildback
better law signed in law
with russian troops amassing on the
ukraine border the president made a
prediction about vladimir putin's next
steps my guess is he will move in
he has to do something as for a
potential american response
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having to fight about
what to do and not do etc but if they
actually do what they're capable of
doing with the force of mass on the
border it is going to be a disaster for
russia the president's suggestion that a
minor incursion might be acceptable
earned strong criticism and concern from
republicans the white house later
clarified any invasion will be met with
a swift severe and united response from
the u.s and allies this is the most
consequential thing that's happened in
the world in terms of war and peace
since world war ii
in the news conference the president
said he believes even vladimir putin
doesn't know quite yet what he's going
to do about ukraine and he repeatedly
declined to specify what kinds of
economic sanctions the united states and
allies might potentially use against
russia nate
vice president kamala harris who we will
speak with later in the show she spoke
about russia and the ukraine ed thank
you so much